of the trace again as is shown on the screen and if it's not clear why we want to write the expression like this the
short answer is that we'd like to understand how projective measurements work for density
matrices and in particular by linearity we have that if the state of X is described by a density Matrix row rather
than a Quantum State Vector s then the probability for the outcome a to appear is given by the trace of the projection
Pi a times the density Matrix row that has to be the case because as we've seen
we can always think about a density Matrix as being a weighted average of pure States and if we average the
corresponding probabilities we get this expression because the trace is a linear function so that's the expression we're
going for and we can clean things up just a little bit to focus in on density
matrices the main point of doing this by the way is to establish a point of reference to what we've already learned
and to see that this description of projective measurements is in fact a special case of a more General description of measurements that we're
about to see so what I'll do now is to replace this description of how projective measurements work for density matrices
with the description for General measurements so we can understand the relationship and here it
is a general measurement not necessarily A projective measurement is described by a collection of positive semi-definite
matrices p 0 through PM minus one that's sum to the identity and if this measurement is performed on X while it's
in a state described by a density Matrix row then each outcome a appears with probability equal to the trace of PA *
Row in short the only thing that's changed is that we've relaxed the condition on these matrices in particular the matrices
don't need to be projection matrices they just need to be positive semi-definite and correspondingly I've replaced the letter Pi with the letter p
because Pi is a conventional name for a projection whereas I like to use the letter P for positive semi-definite
matrices this is a generalization of the description we had for projective measurements by the way because projection matrices are always positive
semi-definite and in fact they can alternatively be defined as positive semi-definite matrices whose igen values
can only be zero and one we can observe that this definition
makes sense in that we always obtain a probability Vector for the outcome probabilities in the following
way first these numbers that I referred to as outcome probabilities are always non- negative real numbers that's
because both PA and row are positive semi-definite and the trace of the product of two positive semi-definite
matrices is always a non- negative real number and I'll leave that for you to think about why that
is and second the numbers have to sum to one because the trace is linear the
matrices p 0 through PN minus1 are required to sum to the identity and density matricies have Trace equal to
one so regardless of what density Matrix row we started with the outcome probabilities will indeed always form a
probability Vector now let's take a look at a few examples I already mentioned that
projective measurements are a special case of General measurements because projections are always positive semi-definite
but it's nice to start simple so let's begin with a standard basis measurement of a cubit we can represent a standard basis
measurement of a cubit by two matrices p 0 and P1 defined as is shown on the screen p 0 is z bra zero and P1 is k1
bra one these are both positive semi-definite matrices and indeed their projections and they clearly sum to the
identity so together they describe a measurement if we apply this measurement to a cubit
in a state described by a density Matrix row then the probability for the alcome zero to appear is the trace of p 0 * row
and the probability for the outcome one is the trace of P1 * row and by the cyclic property of the trace we obtain
the two diagonal entries of row as we expect here's another example where this
time the matrices aren't projections they are positive semidefinite though and they do happen to be density
matrices but that's not important but what is important is that they sum to the identity so together they describe a
measurement we can see what happens when this measurement is performed on a cubit in the plus state for instance just to
see how it works for one example of a state and a calculation of the probabilities is shown on the
screen notice in particular that although the plus state is a pure State and we can represent that state by the quantum State Vector cat Plus we do have
to plug the density Matrix representation of that state which is C plus BR plus into the formulas to get
the probabilities and let me also remark that because we're talking about a destructive measurement there isn't any
specification of the postmeasurement quantum state of this Cubit so all we have is a specification of the outcome
probabilities here's a final example for now and it's a pretty interesting one once again it's a measurement of a
single Cubit and to describe it we'll start by defining four quantum State vectors known as the tetrahedral
States and the reason that they're called the tetrahedral States is because they correspond to the four vertices of
a regular tetrahedron inscribed within the block sphere and to be clear when we say that this is a regular tetrahedron
we mean a four-sided solid where each of the faces is an equilateral triangle so there's a perfect symmetry here every
Edge has the same length and it's the same angle that's formed between any two adjacent
edges and now we can define an interesting measurement with four possible outcomes as is shown on the screen or in words we can take our
matrices to be the density Matrix representations of these states divided by two now these are definitely positive
semi-definite matrices because their density matrices divided by two and you could go through the arithmetic to check
that they do in fact sum to the identity but another way to see that is to think about the Symmetry if we average these four states
together we get the completely mixed state which is at the center of the block sphere but because we're dividing
each one by two rather than four we get twice the completely mixed state which is the identity I won't say anything more about
this measurement for now except to observe that it isn't a projective measurement but it is a nice example and
we'll see it come up again later in the lesson another way to describe general measurements is as channels as we'll now
discuss the idea here is that classical probabilistic States can be represented by diagonal density matrices and so
because measurement outcomes are classical we can think about measurements as being channels where the output is always a diagonal density